pas si mathieu bon assez scolaire se
doutera tout en amour rien et bête on
n'est jamais ridicule tant qu'on est
sincère il n'a fait plus qui peut-être
de ces deux bosses mon plaza tel un
appartement visite moi c'est pas mal ça
démarre on voit le progrès ce que j'aime
rien à rénover à décorer tu trouvera
peut-être une pièce cachée
la part des coûts oui alors oui ça
supposait de blessure et laissé le nous
la seule chose que tu auras à faire pour
trouver ton bonheur est de faire tomber
la cloison de mon coeur partout merde
merci jeu mais si tu cherches bien tu
trouvera peut-être la pièce avec poutres
apparentes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais bon ça va ça laisse rêveur gsm à
écouter des années maintenant mc
lancement c'est au salon wii
ah oui à la renverse d'amour merci
stéphane en tout cas ça vous a plu
oui merci je suis vraiment gaieté et
c'était très beau l'ajoulot cas d'andré
oui bah ouais ouais merci ben voilà pas
très bien vous êtes célibataire vous je
trouve ça oui souvent en tout cas
c'était sincère et vous réservera sa
réponse à la fin de l'émission il va
être un poème mais ont déclaré ensemble
oui
[Rires]